[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
the ever mysterious and mildly confusing
Hogwarts school motto I haven't
encountered many Harry Potter fans that
actually know the motto let alone its
meaning so I think this may be news to a
lot of you the motto is of course in
blazoned on the school crest if you
already knew then well done but for
those that don't know it is Draco Dorman
nunquam to tell and us the motto is
first mentioned by Dumbledore at the end
of his foreword to the 2001 edition
fantastic beasts and where to find them
there seems to be a trend coming from JK
Rowling surrounding the use of Latin as
the school motto many spell names and
other elements of Harry Potter utilise
it in an interview with Bloomsbury
Rowling discusses the nature of the
motto for the first time the interview
asks the question how did you think up
the motto Draco doorman
Anquan to to Landis or never tickle a
sleeping dragon which appears under the
crest is there a story about it
- which Rowling explains you know the
way that most school slogans are things
like persevere and nobility charity and
fidelity or something it just amused me
to give an entirely practical piece of
advice for the hogwarts school motto
then I contacted a friend of mine it was
a professor of classics my Latin was not
up to the job I went to him and asked
him to translate for me I think he
really enjoyed it he rang me up and said
I think I found exactly the right word
toodle and us that was how that was
dreamt up the name is just an idiom
derived from let sleeping dogs lie
it's a magic efficacious if you will it
basically means don't stir up trouble
and don't open up a can of worms don't
stir up a hornet's nest and definitely
don't play with fire if you tickle a
sleeping dragon then you are probably
only causing problems for yourself
problems that can be easily avoided if
you simply didn't tickle a sleeping
dragon essentially Rowling took note of
typical school slogans in their usage
and decided to go against the status quo
while schools and
cool fashion might want the slogans to
represent some broad and profound higher
meaning mildly masked by the ambiguity
of Latin rolling wanted the Hogwarts
slogan to be direct and convey a simple
piece of evidence don't tickle a
sleeping dragon so while you may have
expected the slogan emblazoned on
Hogwarts crest to be something quite
grandiose and spectacular it's really
just the result of Rowling having a bit
of a laugh what's possibly more amusing
is that Harry could not have ignored the
school motto any more during his years
at the school he took on Voldemort in
theory
Dementors dragons mermaids grinned elos
Death Eaters giant spiders mountain
trolls basilisks and more the list goes
on and that pretty much covers it I hope
that you guys enjoyed this video if you
could have chosen a model for Hogwarts
what would you have picked
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]